[Music]
ladies and gentlemen before you hear it
on the news i'm going to tell you myself
about an hour ago we had an incident
where one of the employees stuck their
arm through the cage and the tiger tore
her arm off
i can give you your money back or i can
give you a rain check hello everyone and
welcome to a mysterious new episode of
rt essentials i'm your host mark ellis
and you know true crime stories have
made for must-see tv as far back as the
late 80s and with the rise of streaming
services over the past decade the world
of true crime has become must-see tv as
well and with nearly every platform now
trying to find the next viral phenomenon
you internet sleuths out there have more
options than ever or at least more than
you can shake your mouse at and whether
you like to play along and try to solve
the crime by yourself or just sit back
like a bump on a log
like me and let the pros solve it it
would truly be a crime for you to miss
this list because today we're talking
about the greatest true crime series of
all time
don't f with cats hunting an internet
killer so i called my sister
because my sister is a psychologist and
she studied criminal profiling
she said this person is doing this for
shock value this person is the person
that needs a lot of attention this isn't
the first time it's not going to be the
last time and this is going to get
progressively worse yeah don't mess with
the cats and don't f with cats hunting
an internet killer isn't quite as feline
filled as the title suggests but that
doesn't mean it's not
perfectly satisfying is funny and yes
there are more cat puns on the way this
series covers the events surrounding a
crowd-sourced amateur investigation by a
group of online justice seekers who
tracked down a guy after he posted a
video of himself killing kittens i know
i'm very upset about it too anyway it
turns out the guy is a canadian
pornographic actor which is apparently a
thing and it all develops into a story
involving the killing of a person i know
what you're thinking mark you've cat to
be kitten me right meow
again cats and it's a dark thing so
we're trying to make it fun this
three-part docu-series starts off when a
video called one boy two kittens goes
viral showing the culprit playing with
and eventually suffocating two kittens
that's when a data analyst in las vegas
teams up with a man in los angeles to
start a facebook group this is where
they build evidence by examining the
details of the video to help catch this
guy
we picked apart
[Music]
every little thing in that room
[Music]
then i created a schematic or diagram of
the layout of the room
so everybody understood what each thing
was
while the series does check a lot of
boxes for true crime fans one criticism
it has faced is that it gives fame
seekers an even bigger platform
mashable's allison foreman called it a
fascinating watch examining the risks
that come with taking justice into your
hands but that it struggles to convey a
cohesive message and despite a few
imperfect reviews the series was an
immediate and huge success netflix said
it was one of their top five most
watched documentaries of 2019 despite
being released in december of that year
plus it picked up a creative arts emmy
award for outstanding writing for a
non-fiction program that's like nine
lives worth of accomplishments in just
three episodes am i right okay we're
mercifully done
unsolved mysteries at the beginning of
the investigation i tried to determine
whether mr rivera was in the hotel at
all
so i checked the cameras in the hotel
and there was no footage of them
anywhere it's time to take it back to
the godfather of true crime series the
og pretty much where it all started
unsolved mysteries now unraveling the
history of where the show has aired
through the years is a bit of a mystery
on its own but that's one i'm confident
that even i can solve today this series
has used a documentary format to profile
real-life mysteries like unsolved crimes
missing persons cases and unexplained
phenomenon by way of good old
reenactments and what do reenactments
need that's right actors in fact a few
stars like matthew mcconaughey cheryl
hines daniel day kim ned bellamy and
taryn kilm appeared on the program
before moving on to bigger and arguably
better things probably just bigger
things in one of the documents it says
99.9 percent sure it is a suicide
but when the investigators went through
the room they couldn't find any identity
what began as a series of specials on
nbc back in 1987 became a full-fledged
series by 1988 with a man himself robert
stack serving as host in the only
ominous dramatic way that he knew how
after nine series on nbc the series
moved to cbs in 1997 where it lasted
just two six episode seasons and was
cancelled in 1999. the next year the
series was revived by lifetime where it
aired for two years and 103 episodes
ending in 2002.
can i get a water break that was a lot
of thinking and talking after six years
of mysteries just going unsolved i guess
the series was resurrected by spike tv
in 2008 airing until 2010 and then in
2019 netflix picked up a reboot of the
series which premiered on july 1st 2020
with an additional season ordered for
2022.
uh we can always count on netflix now
that the show is back the consensus from
critics is that the latest reboot is
slick and features compelling cases with
rolling stones daniel kreps saying that
the og still has something left to teach
the genre it helped create and when a tv
series can help solve actual real world
crimes like this one has been doing for
decades let's keep it around as long as
we can shall we
the lady and the dale i thought this was
the beginning of a real life where we
could be a normal family
because this was real
but my secret self
was wondering when it was going to end
when they were going to find out that my
mother was really my father who was in
trouble with the law and now because
true crime knows no boundaries we move
into the world of three-wheeled cars
with the hbo series the lady and the
dale and no matter how many wheels you
got it's a wild ride this certified
fresh four episode series revolves
around the story of entrepreneur
elizabeth carmichael who received
instant stardom during the 1970s gas
crisis when she released a
fuel-efficient three-wheeled vehicle
called the dale but as the car increased
in popularity so did the media scrutiny
surrounding its technology unfolding a
mystery regarding carmichael's
surprising past and her complicated
story as a trans person she had to say
something you know make up something to
keep the waters you know level or else
bad things were gonna happen
and uh
pretty soon bad things did happen she
had to uh you know run for the hills it
features interviews with members of
carmichael's family along with news
anchors journalists and former employees
the critics consensus says the result is
an intoxicating blend of historical
footage candid interviews and animation
that definitely captures carmichael's
incredible life with inku kang from the
washington post saying that there's no
more fantastical yarn than the one spun
here nor a portrait so profoundly human
and if that's not enough to make you
want to take this true crime story for a
test drive after a producer mark duplass
along with his brother j duplass serve
as executive producers under their dupos
brothers productions so you see it's a
fun
and sometimes frightening family affair
all around
wild wild country
she was really
pale
and she told us
tomorrow buguan is going to orchestrate
his death tomorrow devaraj is going to
kill him next we're going to take you to
the oregon desert well you can stay
comfortably where you are we'll just go
there in spirit for the netflix
docu-series wild wild country not to be
confused with will smith's wild wild
west trust me it's a common mistake one
has a giant spider and the other one is
the certified fresh true crime story
hitting netflix in march of 2018 after
premiering at the sundance film festival
and it chronicles the issues that arise
when a controversial guru builds a
utopian city in the oregon desert
causing a massive conflict with local
ranchers things escalate to include a
massive case of illegal wiretapping and
the first ever bioterror attack in the
united states
now you can see why there are two wilds
in the title one wild just does not
capture all of that
wild we started buying the properties in
antelope to secure our existence
as a city
and we took over
the central figures in this twisted tale
include indian guru bhagwan shree
rajneesh aka osho his follower shibham
yadav and his one-time personal
assistant ma anad sheila who emerges as
a provocative spokeswoman for the
commune they along with their community
of followers are part of a story which
is considered a pivotal yet largely
forgotten time in american cultural
history where the country's tolerance
for the separation of church and state
was put to the test and the story didn't
stop with this series as the documentary
film searching for sheila arrived on
netflix in april of 2021 following
osho's former top eight on her first
journey home to india in more than 30
years it aims to shine a little more
light on her alleged involvement and
eventual prosecution for the 1984
bioterror attack in oregon with mark and
jay dupois serving as executive
producers for this series as well the
critics say the wild wild country
succeeds as an intriguing examination of
a forgotten piece of history that must
be seen to be believed with npr's linda
holmes calling it an often bizarre story
that is full of twists and unforgettable
characters
sounds like a wild ride sorry sorry wild
wild ride oh put another one in there
wild wild wild ride check it out
tiger king murder mayhem and madness we
hear it's carol's birthday next month
and we're shipping her two of these
look at the things on that
one day i went out to open up the
mailbox and it just exploded with snakes
there could be an argument made that no
true crime series has impacted pop
culture as swiftly and as powerfully as
our next series in part thanks to a
global pandemic and that's tiger king
murder mayhem and madness this series is
an exploration of the small but deeply
interconnected business of big cat
breeding and its bizarre underworld it
centers around the colorful life of a
zookeeper named joe exotic along with
other big cat conservationists like
carol baskin and jeff lowe and the best
drama here comes from the bitter ongoing
feud between mr exotic and miss baskin
which eventually leads to joe's
conviction under federal murder for
higher statutes see kids even kings can
go to jail here in the united states
especially if they're
tiger king the first season of tiger
king was unleashed on netflix on march
20th 2020 and if that date feels
familiar it's because that's pretty much
the exact time most of america was
officially stuck at home and looking for
something to watch and according to
netflix over 34 million people did watch
this series over his first 10 days of
release ranking is one of the most
successful releases at the time for the
streaming giant hey it's gotta be better
than that imagine vid that all those
celebrities did right did i hear you say
you wanted my
watch
really my watch
they tell me you want my god bed too
the second season accurately titled
tiger king 2 came in november of 2021
and continues on in the aftermath of
joe's imprisonment and further explores
theories surrounding the disappearance
of carol baskin's first husband and then
a spin-off season tiger king the doc
anthel story was released just a month
later in december of 2021 and that dives
into the life of one of joe and carol's
biggest rivals the man known as doc
antle the heir to the tiger throne
perhaps critics and fans dug the
certified fresh first season with the
boston globe's mark shanahan saying that
he learned a few ugly yet important
truths that make tiger king worthwhile
and as far as what critics think of the
second season and the spin-off
let's just say that cat puns like this
kitty has no claws have been used
frequently
atlanta's missing and murdered the lost
children i dream about them all the time
but
i never see a state
i hear these boys
but i'll never see his face
unfortunately not all true crime series
can be shocking in a tiger king kind of
way but rather shocking in a tragic type
of way and that's where atlanta's
missing and murdered the lost children
comes in this five part documentary
series brings new evidence to light in
the abduction and murder of
approximately 30 african-american
children and young adults over a span of
time between 1979 and 1981. now with the
official re-opening of the case 40 years
later by the mayor of atlanta this
inside story sheds new light on these
horrific crimes through exclusive
archival material and interviews with
those closest to the investigation
released in april of 2020 on hbo max the
series kicks off with the initial
disappearance and discovery of two
murdered teenage boys following the
ensuing fear that slowly overtook the
city of atlanta until the prosecution of
23 year old wayne williams found guilty
of murdering two adults and to whom
police attributed the murders of 10
children though he was never charged or
tried in connection with them it's been
a long time
since that trial
and i still
have times when i wake up
at night
wondering what else could we have done
but with many of the children's cases
being closed this series raises new
questions related to the racial tensions
and political clashes of the time
bringing new evidence to light through
never-before-seen footage interviews and
court documents the consensus from
critics is that this true crime series
is as gripping as it is chilling with
valerie complex from collider saying
that it brilliantly shows various
vantage points giving the viewer enough
information to decide what side they're
on
the jinx the life and deaths of robert
durst i explained to him you've been
arrested for you know homicide your bond
has been set at 250 000
and he asked me he said well
what should i do
and i said i don't know
do you have 250 000
and he just calmly looked at me and he
goes
well not on me not since fred durst in
the late 90s someone with the last name
durst gotten people this riled up and
it's all thanks to hbo's the jinx the
life and deaths of robert durst this
2015 series was directed and produced by
andrew jarecki and produced and shot by
mark smirling the oscar-nominated team
behind 2003's certified fresh
documentary film capturing the freedmen
they're back at it with this
groundbreaking six-part documentary that
explores the odd history of real estate
heir robert durst the still unsolved
1982 disappearance of his wife and the
murders of family friends susan berman
and neighbor morris black the series is
the result of 10 years of research by
the filmmakers who bring forth police
files key witnesses never before seen
footage private prison recordings and
countless pages of formerly hidden
documents
if you had him sitting here what would
you say to him
what did you do with it
because he's the key is with him all
that is expertly stitched together with
an extended revealing interview that
jarecki conducts with durst the pair
developed a unique relationship
following the release of all good things
chireki's 2010 feature film starring
ryan gosling and kirsten dunst that is
all about you guessed it durst's life
the jinx really registered in the pop
culture ethos on the eve of the final
episodes airing in march of 2015 when
durst was arrested in new orleans by the
fbi
it was for a first degree murder warrant
in connection to berman's death from an
investigation based on new evidence
presented in the series you see mom tv
does do good things which is why i watch
it all day
audiences and critics were definitely
feeling this series with npr's eric
degens saying that it created a new
version of true crime television high
praise considering the world of true
crime is definitely not lacking in the
content department
dateline nbc i was on your regular
run-of-the-mill hoodlum
and it's something that i regret
but it's a it's a part of my life that i
can't avoid or deny you know i was a kid
growing up in the bronx and um i learned
the wrong habits
but that doesn't make me a murderer this
next series has changed a lot since it
began back in 1992 but hey who hasn't
i'm still wearing my acid wash jeans
we're talking about the one and only
dateline nbc are you bored in a hotel
room don't worry dateline nbc is on what
started out as nbc's flagship general
interest news magazine has evolved over
the past 30 years to become a show that
now mainly focuses on true crime stories
and for that we say thank you and if it
feels like you see it everywhere you're
right it's repackaged hour-long episodes
of dateline that you'll see on all kinds
of cable and satellite channels and
again in every hotel room thank you so
much for helping me sleep and keeping me
up some nights the program debuted on
march 31 1992 when people were listening
to right said fred's i'm too sexy on the
radio they're not listening to that
anymore and they drove to see white men
can't jump in the theater which i
actually did watch again last night the
reality is that frank is 20 years old
right now
he has the mentality of about a year old
baby the original anchors who arguably
became household names thanks to this
show were stone phillips and jane pauley
and when the program joined with the
previously separate news magazine now
with tom broke on katie couric those two
nobodies became part of dateline as well
and through the years the anchor seat
was also kept warm by names like brian
gumbel maria shriver and curry joe
exotic and lester holt
i only made up one of those the series
began by airing two nights a week
peaking at five nights a week in 1999
and 2000 as things began to evolve a
number of popular spin-off series were
born from dateline like to catch a
predator wild wild web there's that wild
wild again and to catch a con man plus
in february of 2021 dateline launched
its first ever docu-series the widower a
five-hour true crime saga about a man
who married six women four of whom died
but if you feel like you're a dateline
nbc fan but have no one in your life who
shares that love fear not a number of
stars have admitted their obsession with
the show over the years including stevie
nicks michael buble bill hader maui sims
dax shepherd christian chenoweth and
mark ellis a well-liked host
the staircase and the last i saw her was
when i was there and she was just
walking walking here
that's it that was the last i saw
kathleen
alive
no she was alive when i found her but
barely our next true crime series the
staircase features a guy who was once
known for writing stories but became
even more known for the stories that
were being written about him once he
became a suspect in his wife's death the
story centers around novelist michael
peterson whose wife died in 2001 after
what he claimed was a fall down some
stairs at their home but when the
medical examiner determined that there
was more foul play involved peterson
became part of a murder investigation
and viewers get to soak in a real-life
courtroom thriller as it plays out
following the investigation from the
arrest to the verdict reach in the
ensuing trial the series which now lives
on netflix in 13 episodes began with
eight episodes back in 2005
airing on various networks in europe and
has a two-hour abbreviated version on
abc here in the united states but as
developments were made in the case more
episodes were added in 2013 and again in
2018 when netflix picked it up and made
it available as one cohesive series
if i spend too much time
arguing that he's innocent
i in essence i relieve the state of its
burden of proof
i invite the jury to weigh well is
rudolph right or is hardening right the
success of the staircase led to a
dramatic limited series for hbo max
which is an adaptation of the
docu-series it stars colin firth as
peterson tony coletta as his wife
kathleen along with sophie turner
patrick schwarzenegger rosemarie dewitt
and others in the cast as well the
consensus from critics on this series is
that it offers a gripping and detailed
depiction of the complex justice system
with indy wire's steve green saying that
if the staircase is a puzzle it's one
that still works no matter how you
decided to arrange the pieces okay that
settles it who wants to come over for
puzzle night my place
four of you can fit
making a murderer i think stephen was a
representative in that case of the
entire avery family
and how the sheriff's department saw
them as
kind of a problem and definitely uh
undesirable members of the community for
lack of a better term and finally this
true crime series making a murderer had
much of america making themselves
investigators for a good portion of
2015. the series premiered on netflix in
december of 2015 after a decade in the
making and it tells the story of a
wisconsin man who spent nearly 20 years
in prison for a crime he didn't commit
before being exonerated the lawsuit he
filed against manitoba county in
wisconsin and several people involved
with his arrest and the subsequent
murder of a 25 year old woman who was
last seen on you guess it his property i
didn't know
what to do how to handle it
you know because it was putting too much
pressure on me
people would come up to me and say
you're doing that and doing that
you know not in the winter
and middle of the road
that made me look like a
that guy was no good person avery and
his nephew brendan dassey were tried and
convicted of the crime but a couple of
columbia graduate students got a hold of
the story and thought it would make an
interesting documentary and i think you
could say they were right those columbia
kids are pretty good eggs and the first
season generated plenty of publicity
both good and bad with officials in
wisconsin insisting that not all the
evidence is being presented in the
series and the certified fresh first
season wasn't just a hit with true crime
hungry fans critics were into it as well
sam adams not the beer guy the rolling
stone critic said that the series goes
deep instead of broad exploiting the
inherent drama of a murder investigation
and subsequent criminal trials plus the
first season received six prime time
emmy nominations and took home four
statues including one for outstanding
documentary series
talk about making a success story and
there you have it our list of the
greatest true crime series of all time
the mystery has been solved and now the
next true crime i'm ready to solve is uh
who ate all of the leftovers out of the
fridge there's only two people here
ed and i'm one of them
and i was looking forward to that slice
of pizza thanks for checking out rt
essentials i'm mark ellis who went to
wake forest known as the columbia of the
appalachian mountain region and remember
if your neighbor seems like they're up
to something fishy they definitely are
and you should make a docu-series about
it and have me as an executive producer
we'll see you next time here on rt
ascension
[Music]
you